[Music]
a final farewell for a superstar Dame
Olivia Newton-John's Hometown Melbourne
paid tribute to one of their own tribute
2 from singers and celebrities the world
over she was fun she was beautiful she
was kind
those kind of people don't come along
very often
so we should treasure her memory
and never forget what she gave the world
I considered her a great friend as well
as a fellow Entertainer and Olivia to
quote one of your songs I Honestly Love
You born in the UK Newton John moved to
Australia as a child she later went back
got her first big break to Global Fame
the hit 1978 movie Grease she was Sandy
next to John Travolta's Deli
Newton John stole hearts and more than
six months after her death
so many are still broken she was my safe
space
my guide my biggest fan
and the Earth beneath my feet
every day with Olivia was Supernatural
every day with Olivia
was a bit of magic
[Music]
moving a medley of Newton John's biggest
hits one of her greatest fans Delta
Goodman
[Music]
courageous to the end Olivia Newton-John
still inspires her fans
in this concert their last goodbye to a
Leading Light in the world of music
Nicole Johnston
Sky News Sydney